the dust is settling in New Hampshire
and the reigning champ remains
undefeated former president Trump
notching another huge win in the GOP
Primary and defeating Nikki Haley by a
significant margin of 11 points the
victory makes Trump the first GOP
candidate since 1976 to win both Iowa
and New Hampshire and there's no doubt
about it the momentum is firmly on
Trump's side but Nikki Haley is refusing
to call it quits I want to congratulate
Donald Trump on his victory tonight
you've all heard the chatter among the
political class they're falling all over
themselves saying this race is over it's
not over well I have news for all of
them New Hampshire is first in the
nation it is not the last in the nation
former president Trump was not too
pleased to hear that Nikki Haley was
staying in the race and he went scorched
Earth on her I can go up and I can say
to everybody oh thank you for the
victory it's wonderful it's or I can go
up and say who the hell was the impostor
that went up on the stage before and
like claimed a victory she did very
poorly actually I watched her in the
fancy dress that probably wasn't so
fancy come up I said what's she doing we
won Nikki Haley getting a little help
last night from people who aren't
registered Republican
Fox News voter analysis says 67% of
Independents picked Haley as did 94% of
Undeclared Democrats and it looks like a
liberal Network caught up with one of
them I voted for Nikki Haley and it was
certainly a strategic vote while I
wouldn't vote for her in a general
election particularly on our differences
with uh climate change solution and
women's right to bodily autonomy or
incarceration rates I think a vote for
Nikki Haley is helps diminish Trump's
influence and the RNC in their
nomination but has also a vote towards
democracy you know um Martha it's not
the first time we're hearing this that
people who took advantage of the fact
that Independence 40% of them can and
can vote in the New Hampshire primary
for either major party kind of did it to
play games but they won't vote for Nikki
Haley in a general election it's not a
huge slice uh who actually played that
game there were about 4,000 voters who
filed early enough Democrats true Dem RS
who wanted to participate they had to do
it by the beginning of October in order
to do that this is the live free die or
Live Free or Die state right I'm sorry I
can't talk I've been but so the largest
political party the largest political
group in that in in the state of New
Hampshire is Independence they're larger
than Republicans and Democrats and we're
seeing this around the country we're
seeing 43% now register as Independence
and I think what is going on here
besides
that young man who and I don't I think
that's a very small slice of the pie in
reality um but I think what's going on
here is you're getting something called
and there's a very interesting article
in the free press this week called the
Great scramble and you're seeing
movement in these parties you're seeing
people who are you know president Trump
has created this movement that is kind
of in and of itself its own very Fierce
driven force in the country and he's
getting people he's getting Latinos he's
getting black voters he's now getting
College women he's getting a lot of
people crossing into that category that
were never there before and if that
continues to increase that's going to be
a very very uh compelling argument for
him for another term but you also have
you know these people who feel left out
by that process who consider themselves
conservative who are looking for
something else and the question is
whether or not you know as a sort of
Quasi incumbent someone who was
president and now isn't president wants
to be president again what kind of
numbers does he need to get over that
hurdle you know so is he is he getting
those numbers to get back in if you're
just an incumbent president you're going
to be with your own party at 84 85 90%
in some cases right so this is just what
we watch you know in terms of the
politics and how it all moves over the
course of the next 10 months all right
Greg um you know it sounds like Nikki
Haley is claiming Victory she came in
third in Iowa she came in second in New
Hampshire it looks like she's going to
get Tron North Carolina her own state
where you've got everyone lieutenant
governor the governor the Congress
people both United States senators uh
she's going to get Tron Carolina what
what what is she thinking this is the
system this is what you you can't you
can't concede until you concede right
it's like then all the money goes away
and she's got to stay so it's like we
all we we can all see it she can all see
it and clearly she did win the vote of
Democrats if the Democrats hadn't been
in there it would have been moral
lopsided than like a a sexy dude contest
between me and kilme this reminds me of
the GameStop controversy you remember
all the amateur Traders like drove up
the price of a video game company and
the Press went nuts and then the company
you know returned to obscurity and the
media acted like it never happened I
feel like that's what this is like it's
a great story for a couple of days but
it's artificially created and there's
something about Trump whenever he's in a
race everybody else sounds like a
politician or acts like a politician
that's an and it forces is people to
choose their lanes and and Nikki uh to
my shag grin I'm not even sure I'm using
that word correctly to my shag grin she
chose the identity Lane and which fed
the media and fed the Democrats and got
her Democrats but for for me as a as a
conservative libertarian it turns me off
and it turns off Republicans because we
get enough of that identity baloney from
the other side so it felt like she
wasn't running against Trump but running
against the Party by pandering to
Democrats it was almost like her
strategy was hey I'm not as racist as
the party I belong to so she made she
talked about her race and Mentor gender
but these post-mortems always undermine
the manufactured hoopla that precedes it
right we spend a week creating all this
energy anxiety and excitement and then
oh yeah we knew how this was going to go
it's like people building up weathermen
building up a giant snow mageddon and
then you only get 2
Ines this is where you insert the Jesse
Waters joke okay that you told
him yeah all right um viewers you know
I'll ask I'll ask this of you um Jessica
the truth is that last night CNN MSNBC
again they decided to dip out of
coverage When Donald Trump said uh uh
took the stage you know if the the
Democrats claim that they're the
Protectors of democracy they don't even
want to have Americans here someone who
is destined to be the party's nominee
what what how was that
Democratic well I think they dipped out
of the coverage when he lied about
winning New Hampshire in 20120 that was
it was a fact check it wasn't like we
just don't want to see him it was
different in Iowa they didn't or at
least MSNBC didn't want to take it and
reachel mat talk about he did win primar
he that wasn't he okay but that's what
they no he won the Primary but he lost
handedly obviously to Joe Biden in the
general right but that was
what he was talking about but but what
about the concept of not allowing a man
I mean don't they trust the American
people to make decisions so that they
should tell us what to think I am all
for putting him out there as much as
possible and letting people continue to
see it because the truth of the matter
is the more people see of Donald Trump
the more they dislike him and vote
against him and that's what happened
they hit us four years of the presidency
and on the campaign Trail in 2020 he was
a turnoff for people and that's why he
lost by several million votes um but I
don't work at CNN or MSNBC there's
obviously a reason that they make their
decisions and and that's the path that
they want to go down I think that we
should show all the candidates I like
that Dean Phillips shows up and he talks
to people here in RFK Jr I think it says
something about who they believe are
going to vote for them and what their
intentions are in terms of being quote
good Democrats they're either covering
the election or they're not yeah if
you're covering the election on New
Hampshire and Iowa kns when they come
out to do their speech you take the
speech if you want to talk about it
afterwards and critique it fine but you
can't you can't give people you know
take away their opportunity to watch it
they can switch turn the channel and
watch us because we're going to show
that that's great and we had great
coverage and I was thrilled to be part
of it and you guys did a wonderful job
I'm not agreeing with the point I would
have aired it in terms of the outcome
and I said this in Iowa as well it does
liberals no favors to deny the successes
that Trump has had what he did in Iowa
was historic getting past 50% there's a
huge win last night like you said it
hasn't been done since 1976 but that
doesn't change the fact that there are
these huge flashing red lights for the
Republican party and that's what Nikki
Haley is talking about so that she won
67% of Independence if that Trend
continues and it's higher than it was in
Iowa and I doubt it will increase to
South Carolina but we know that
Independents were who decided the
election in 2020 and then two really big
numbers that matter that have jumped
from Iowa 43% of her supporters in Iowa
said I won't vote for him in the general
election that went up to 70% in New
Hampshire and then the question in the
exit polls about what happens if Donald
Trump is convicted of a felony right he
has these 91 uh counts out there in Iowa
32% said that they wouldn't support him
and that number J jumped to 50% right
you cannot win a general election with
those kinds of numbers and that's the
case that Nikki Haley's making and why
these Republican donors will continue to
pump money into an alternative because
there are Republicans who are extremely
dissatisfied okay but Charlie let me ask
you this the fact that in both New
Hampshire and in Iowa immigration came
in first the economy came in second
there's no question if you want to talk
about whether or not Trump is going to
win everyone all the polls show that
Trump is stronger than anyone on
immigration and and and those issues are
most important among everybody
especially Independents it's not just
Republicans who care about it I also
think it's very interesting uh to hear
Democrats are always saying oh no we
want to face Donald Trump because he'll
be so easy to beat but every opportunity
they get they go out and vote for for
Nikki Haley so I don't I I I don't
really understand what the strategy
there is um but you know I I you know
stepping back big picture here um Nikki
Haley is uh you know if you want to know
what money does in politics money allows
her to stay in the race and that's why
she's staying in the race the reason
Ronda sandz had to get out of the race
is he had no money left right um and so
she's going to be able and my my
suspicion is that she's going she's out
with an ad already she's going to uh
sort of test the waters for about a week
and kind of see if the numbers move in
South Carolina and then make a decision
after that because if she goes into
South Carolina she will have lost uh
Iowa New Hampshire and Nevada and then
she's going to be going into her home
state and she has to reckon with the
idea that you know she obviously thinks
she has a a bright future and of course
in Republican politics uh you know the
the runner up from last time is always
in the best position and between you
know she's going to try to consider
herself uh that runner up but do you
want to fall into the ash heap of people
like Al Gore and John Edwards who lost
their own state which is like Beyond
humiliating it is and uh and and I so I
think that you know at some point uh and
then that big money that is behind her
because you're right they don't like
Trump and and you know another thing
about the big scramble you know we talk
about third party candidates and and you
know third party uh the American system
is very hostile to third party
candidates but Donald Trump is sort of
like our first Third Party candidate our
first independent to ever run and he
pisses everybody off Republicans and
Democrats which by the way I think is a
very good thing and and not the the
least of which is the fact that he has
undone you know uh the answer to every
election uh in memory has been money if
you have more money you always win
except in the case of Donald Trump he
beat Hillary Clinton he beat Nikki Haley
and Ronda santz even though they
outspend him massively it's a mve the
enthusiasm is very it's very visceral
it's very real when you're out on
campaign very real but he still loses
election we'll see it's different time
ahead the media and Democrats want to
put Grandpa Joe in the basement again
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else